and then on the economic side one of the
big things is you know I could see you
say this is like the number one debate
in finance right now inflationary or
deflationary environment in the short
term and an inflationary reverse
deflationary environment of long term
where one do you come out on that and
two how do you think that affects the
market yeah it's a great question and
definitely the question of the I think
the year you know just from an economic
standpoint I mean you're looking at 20
to 30 percent unemployment
you know retail is the lowest retail
spending has been the lowest it's ever
been on record a factory output I think
hasn't been this low since World War two
you know there have been local
government and state and local
government shortfalls Travel has been
decimated and you know the SMP is
slightly damaged not afraid and so you
know we're obviously saying massive
spending the Fed has expanded its
balance sheet you know nine trillion
plus and so what that tells me is for
those that are familiar with the
Cantillon effect is a lot of this just
hasn't been circulated into the economy
we haven't had you know prices reflect
this fresh supply and it may very well
just be absorbed and you know show no
changes like Japan has been printing
forever and they're still in
deflationary stagnation and the reason
is because even though we try to
illustrate economics through you know
various equations like MV equals PQ we
can't apply physics equations to the
economy it is not the problem with
economics that tries to present itself
as physics is that there are often many
solutions to market problems and the
inverse is also true one solution can
work for a variety of different markets
and the reason is because the
relationship between you know different
parties within the market are not
readily apparent or understood and so
you see a lot of exotic you know
derivatives you see a lot of interesting
you know reshuffling you know balance
sheets and just a lot of things that are
not really apparent so to think that
it's going to be a seesaw where you have
one
it cost something else on the other end
I think is naive at best if not you know
there are speculations that we can make
in terms of what will happen short term
versus long term short term prices are
going down
people aren't employed they can't spend
even if you're giving them a 1200 for a
month it's not going to stimulate the
economy the way you think it's going to
and so that is of course what we know is
deflationary and as a deflationary
environment and you know we have apply
this to Bitcoin just yet but to give the
Bitcoin angle to this you know if prices
are going lower and like you know you
can go to Hawaii for $50 but you know
the US dollar is stronger your
purchasing power goes up in these
environments right and so bitcoins
derivative as a store value all of a
sudden is not as enticing but what we
foresee is that you know a lot of the
printing that we're doing now is going
to have ramifications down the line
these things compound and that's when
Bitcoin becomes you know a more
attractive asset class at least in the
u.s. now this isn't the case for
sovereign for weak sovereign borrowers
that are you know have their debt
denominated in u.s. currencies you know
who have to stimulate their economy in
order to just maintain supply chains and
as a consequence experienced
hyperinflation this is happening now
regardless of whether or not the u.s. is
going through a deflation Airi you know
period and what are they going to do
rely on swap lines so they don't even
have a reserve currency like it's absurd
so I'm just happy that you know Bitcoin
at least gives a lot of these folks the
ability to exit or you know reset